[Musik]
es sind die letzten stunden vor lockdown
nummer zwei in deutschland und die
letzten minuten bis gast führte
schließen müssen
wer weiß für wie lange so wirklich weiß
es niemand
und diese harten regeln die sollen jetzt
hart durchgesetzt werden wie hier schon
in der letzten nacht die masten pflicht
in köln wer jetzt noch feiert wird in
handschellen abgeführt und dem wird die
maske notfalls von der polizei auch
wieder aufgesetzt was macht das alles
mit unserem land und können wir uns
diesen zweiten lockdown überhaupt
leisten dass jetzt alles bei bild über
diesen zweiten lockdown möchte ich
sprechen mit meinen gästen
fdp-fraktionschef christian lindner der
landwirtschaftsministerin julia klöckner
dem csu-landesgruppenchef alexander
dobrindt und der ministerpräsident von
mecklenburg vorpommern der
ministerpräsidentin manuela schwesig vor
glock ich möchte direkt mit ihnen
beginnen lockdown in deutschland waren
sie am wochenende noch mal unterwegs und
haben ein glas wein im restaurant
genossen
ja aber auch so aus wir waren essen in
der tat aber in einem restaurant bei
denen wir wissen das gar nicht so viel
los ist und wir werden natürlich auch
die heimische gastronomie die regionale
unterstützen indem man dort zb dann auch
essen abholen kann und diese möglichkeit
besteht ja ich möchte ihn einmal
exklusive bilder zeigen die uns
zugespielt wurden von der nacht gestern
abend in berlin das ist der club the
pearl gestern nacht und dieser klub
hatte eigentlich angekündigt keine party
zu veranstalten diese halloween party
abzusagen
und hier sieht man wie trotzdem gefeiert
wurde eine
legale halloween party vor schwesig wenn
sie diese bilder sehen was geht ihnen da
durch den kopf
ich finde es unverantwortlich gestern
konnten die kids nicht durch die straßen
ziehen
nirgendwo wurde geklingelt und die
kinder haben verzichtet und hier wird so
eine party gemacht das ist auch mit
blick auf die gastronomen die ab morgen
schließen müssen die sich an alles für
möglich gehalten haben echt
unverhältnismäßig und dass es geht
eigentlich gar nicht das ist so ungefähr
als ob ich mich betrinken und dann noch
meine kinder ins auto setzte und dann
fröhlich durch die gegend fahre ich habe
dafür null verständnis und ich finde
dass es klare konsequenzen haben muss
was für konsequenzen schweben ihnen da
vor ort müssen die verantwortlichen zur
rechenschaft gezogen werden wir haben
dafür klare
regeln getroffen ich weiß jetzt es war
nicht in meinem bundesland deswegen kann
ich jetzt nicht sagen wie es da vor ort
läuft aber es ist doch klar dass man
sowas nicht hinnehmen kann und ich finde
auch innerhalb dieser branche muss
wirklich mit diesen schwarzen schafen
gesprochen werden sie kann nicht sein
dass die einen ist jetzt wirtschaftlich
hart trifft in die anderen tun so als
gäbe es kein problem
herr dobrindt wenn sie die bilder aus
berlin sehen von gestern abend was
wirklich richtig mit dem lockdown erst
in knapp einer stunde zu beginnen naja
es war auf jeden fall richtig dass wir
diese entscheidung getroffen hat
für den montag weil wir einfach auch
zeit brauchen und das zeigen ja auch
genau diese bilder um zu kommunizieren
um verständnis zu entwickeln um zu
zeigen was sind eigentlich die probleme
warum wir wieder in so einen kleineren
lockdown hinein müssen warum wir
weiterhin eine hohe dynamik bei
infektionszahlen haben müssen und ja es
ist richtig das was der club betreiber
macht das geht schlichtweg nicht und das
was die gäste machen
da muss man unterscheiden da fehlt
offensichtlich noch am verständnis dafür
dass es eine zwingende notwendigkeit
gibt wenn wir uns vor infektionen
schützen wollen dass wir halt auf solche
partys jetzt wieder verzichten müssen
und deswegen ist es zwingend notwendig
dass politik darauf reagiert indem sie
weiter kommuniziert und den menschen
erklärt warum wir das tun und warum wir
es uns nicht leisten können dass die
infektionszahlen so steil weiter nach
oben gehen die wir das in den letzten
tagen und wochen erlebt haben
herr lindner haben sie verständnis für
die jungen leute die da nochmal
halloween feiern wollten bevor sie in
den locker umgeht
nein dafür habe ich kein verständnis und
das hat auch nichts mit halloween zu tun
das wäre auch in den letzten wochen
schon falsch und im übrigen auch nicht
gestattet gewesen
das ist doch genau das problem dass
massen events und solche partys in den
letzten wochen und monaten haben
stattfinden können und die haben das
infektionsgeschehen dramatisch mit
verschlechtert nur diese illegalen
partys können jetzt nicht
instrumentalisiert werden um das
schließen des kleinen italieners um die
ecke zu begründen
der mit großem abstand und mit teuren
hygiene konzepten dafür sorge trägt dass
die gäste sich dort eben nicht
infizieren
das eine das sind illegale partys die
gehören unterbunden aber er hat
nichts zu tun mit der ganz großen zahl
von gaststätten betrieben hotels museen
und kultureinrichtungen die investiert
haben wie hygiene konzepte und wo selbst
das lka das robert-koch-institut sagt
von denen geht in wahrheit keine
infektionsgefahr raus weil sie am
wochenende in berlin noch mal unterwegs
beim kleinen italiener um die ecke
nein ich war nicht beim kleinen
italiener um die ecke wir haben uns zu
viert im privaten rahmen getroffen
wenn sie jetzt diesen werten erklären
müssen warum sie dagegen sind dass sie
oder wie sie gekämpft haben sozusagen
für diesen weg wie können sie dann
erklären dass die landesregierung wo sie
mitregieren unter anderem in
nordrhein-westfalen eben genau das
mitmachen ganz einfach das
infektionsgeschehen und das
krisen-management werden gesteuert in
wahrheit zentral von der bundesregierung
wir stellen keinen ministerpräsidenten
die ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten haben mit der
bundeskanzlerin eine krisenstrategie
verabredet und unter nutzung der
sogenannten richtlinienkompetenz haben
diese ministerpräsidenten und eine
ministerpräsidentin dass in den landes
kabinetten begründet ich hielte es
wir haben das intensiv beraten wolfgang
kubicki hat das ja auch öffentlich
gemacht dass diese frage auch sehr
ernsthaft in kiel beispielsweise
diskutiert worden ist wir hielten es
jetzt nicht für verantwortbar in einer
krise koalitionsregierungen zu sprengen
für entscheidungen die in war dem
kanzleramt geprägt werden also
wahnsinnig darüber nachgedacht
vielleicht mit dem koalitionsbruch zu
drohen in wolfgang und wolfgang kubicki
hat ein solches interview gegeben aber
ansonsten bin ich kein landespolitiker
die frage müssen sie dann an die anderen
kollegen richten wolfgang kubicki hat
dazu aussagen gemacht frau schwesig
sie sind eine der ministerpräsidenten
die in der schalte waren die das mit
entschieden haben warum muss der kleine
italiener um die ecke sowie christian
lindner ist formuliert schließen
es wir haben eine andere situation ich
glaube wir haben eben ziemlich alle
deutlich gemacht dass solche illegalen
partys nicht gehen
und ich finde ganz klar dass wer sich an
solche regel nicht hält dass man
überlegen muss ob der dann zukünftig
überhaupt noch auf machen kann weil er
damit einer ganzen branche schade aber
wir haben eine neue situation wir haben
nicht nur das problem dieser illegalen
partys sondern wir haben das problem
dass das virus mitten in der bevölkerung
ist in allen bereichen und dass es stark
drückt wir haben es eigentlich ja in
allen bundesländern stark und das wir 75
prozent der bei 75 prozent der
infektionen kann man nicht mehr
sozusagen rausfinden was war die ursache
wir haben leute die sich ganz korrekt an
die regeln gehalten haben wo es
überhaupt gar keine sorge gibt dass die
bürger legalen partie waren
und die haben sich trotzdem infiziert
und davon haben wir eine große vielzahl
insbesondere in meinem bundesland
berichten mir dass die gesundheitsämter
und deswegen können wir keinen bereich
ausschließen wir können nicht sagen es
gibt im bereich da passiert nichts und
wir müssen jetzt diese welle brechen
weil wir sonst in drei wochen
die intensivstationen voll haben und
dann nicht mehr adäquat versorgen können
und wenn es jetzt um dieses brechen der
welle geht geht es darum 75 prozent der
kontakte zu reduzieren und wir stehen
vor der frage wo reduzieren wir die
kontakte und wir haben eine ganz klare
linie
das was lebensnotwendig ist dass die
kinder in die schule gehen können dass
die produktion offen ist dass der
einzelhandel mit den supermärkten
funktioniert also die bevölkerung
versorgt wird das hat jetzt vorrang und
die privaten bereiche die freizeit
bereiche wie zum beispiel urlaub machen
essen gehen das muss jetzt nach rang
haben es geht nicht darum dass wir den
lask würden sagen ihr habt das falsch
gemacht oder bei euch wir es unsicher es
geht darum wo reduziere ich die kontakte
und da hat jetzt gerade eine kita und
schule vorrang für restaurants oder
hotels nicht schütteln mit dem kopf an
wo nebel entschuldigung noch letzte satz
wer nicht will dass die kontakte zum
beispiel im bereich ich bleibe jetzt mal
konkret in gastro und hotels reduziert
werden der muss sagen wo sie woanders
reduziert werden sollen so zu tun als ob
man nichts reduzieren müsste wäre
fahrlässig handeln sie fahrlässig wenn
sie sagen kneipen und restaurants briten
endlich offen bleibt
nein es gibt ja einen punkt der wirklich
nachvollziehbar ist und wo es auch gar
keinen streit gibt das ist die frage
reduzierung der kontakt es kann jetzt
nicht große gruppen geben die zusammen
feiern jetzt ist nicht der zeitpunkt
auch für große hochzeiten aber wenn man
zu zweit vielleicht auch mit dem
menschen mit dem man in häuslicher
lebensgemeinschaft lebt in die
gaststätte geht davon geht schlicht kein
infektionsrisiko aus und die gaststätte
nicht unterbricht ungern aber wir haben
die zahlen allein die gefahr ist ja dass
das wieder von gerichten zurückgeholt
wird frau schwesig hat die erfahrung
gemacht mit einem beherbergungs verbot
viele andere auch wenn man dinge
schließt ohne dass es tatsächlich
verhältnismäßig ist setzt man sich hohen
rechtlichen gefahren aus das untergräbt
das vertrauen der menschen in den start
wir wollen mit
wir wollen wir kommen gleich zurück zu
ihnen vor schwesig wir wollen einmal
sprechen mit jemandem der direkt
betroffen ist und zwar ist mein kollege
michael engelberg in münster in einer
kneipe michael jetzt gleich schluss bei
die richtig guten abend paul guten abend
ins studio ja wir stehen hier in der
traditionsgasthof nie kleiner
kiepenkerle im herzen von münster dieses
restaurants seit 65 jahren in der hand
der familie ludolf und dem rock herr
rudolf sie haben jetzt schon zwei monate
zu gemacht jetzt geht's gleich wieder
dabei darum den schlüssel umzudrehen wie
haben sie die letzten zwei monate ja wie
haben sie die durchlebt und nehmen sie
die politiker mit die da theoretisch
darüber sprechen aber sie betrifft setzt
nun ja wir gehen schon mit sehr sehr
hängenden köpfen ich habe daraus wären
unsere mitarbeiter wir können das ganze
nicht wirklich nachvollziehen und
greifen warum wir jetzt die schwarzen
schafe sein sollen
die die infektions treiber sind wir
haben in den letzten drei vier tagen
sehr viel zuspruch und solidarität
erfahren
auch die letzten tage war das restaurant
aber nochmal gut gefüllt die natürlich
zwar noch mit zwei drei oder vier
personen
aber die leute haben sie sicher gefühlt
und wir können den eindruck auch nur
wiedergeben das wir sehr sehr viel dafür
getan haben freilich auch investiert
haben die lüftungsanlagen auf vordermann
zu bringen plexiglas wende zu
installieren die kontaktdaten vernünftig
zu verfolgen alleine diese kontaktdaten
zu tausenden aufzubewahren zu zu
archivieren und solchen sagen wir auf
die abgefragt wurden bei uns oder bei
kollegen dass hier die ich kenne nicht
ein einziges mal und ich das ist echt
schwierig denn sie ihr team jetzt
zusammen das ist ja über 50 leute sind
hier sind hier beschäftigt die haben
alle sorgen wie kann ich wie kann ich
meine miete bezahlen wie geht s weiter
gerade das gespräch ja wir sehen uns
vielleicht in vier wochen wieder müssen
wir alle die daumen drücken und alles
schön die die maßnahmen einhalten
wie ist die stimmung in ihrem team sehr
bescheiden wir hatten heute morgen noch
ein team meeting abteilungs weise in
ganz kleinen gruppen damit was überhaupt
stemmen können um auch noch mal die
aktuellen
sachstände wiederzugeben die geplant
sind dabei uns fehlen tatsächlich noch
sehr sehr sehr sehr viele antworten auf
diverse fragen wie es weitergehen soll
mit den hilfen die wir bekommen sollen
wie wir auch weiter arbeiten können
damit auch in der phase die jetzt
geschlossen ist also wir sehen dass 75%
hilfsgelder geben soll
dürfen wir uns die letzten 25 prozent
selber erarbeiten oder wird derjenige
der arbeitet bestraft ist es also im
endeffekt so können wir die 25 prozent
im außer haus geschäft machen oder
können wir sollten einfach die füße
hochlegen und am ende gibt's sowieso
dasselbe gilt das ist ein riesengroßer
baustellen aktuell noch offen aber wir
müssen es bis morgen eigentlich wissen
apropos bis morgen jetzt werden wir mal
eben vor die tür gehen jetzt gucken wir
mal dass ich der festen und wir hier
nicht noch auf den letzten metern hin
fallen ja jetzt stehen wir nämlich vor
dem kleinkind kern und helau darf ja
auch wenn es nur symbolisch ist jetzt
wird die tür geschlossen für die
nächsten begehrtesten firmen wochen
erstmal helau doch was ist das für ein
gefühl jetzt so wissen alles ist
irgendwie ungewiss das ist eine
landschaft beschissen es ist wirklich
nicht gerade schön das gefühl wenn ich
nicht wissen wie es weitergehen soll
wann es weitergehen soll
klar steht der november im raum aber
jetzt sind wir doch alle mal ehrlich
welche indikatoren haben wir mit vier
rechnen können und wissen können dass es
danach nicht auch noch weitergeht mit
dem lockdown wir waren gut gerüstet wir
sind der meinung dass wir gut
aufgestellt waren die gäste haben das
auch akzeptiert die investitionen wurden
getätigt jetzt stehen wir wieder da wo
wir im märz gestanden haben
kein fortschritt bisher tatsächlich ja
paul doors gehört herrn rudolf geht es
beschissen vielleicht ein etwas hartes
wort aber zurück gespielt in die
politikerrunde antworten sind bei herrn
rudolf und seinem team sehr willkommen
zurück nach berlin
ja vielen dank michael für die
eindrucksvollen bilder von dort mehr
dobrindt das gefühl ist beschissen sagt
dieser wird können sie denn versprechen
dass am ersten dezember eröffnen darf
erstmal verstehe ich die frustration und
auch den ärger und es stimmt ja
die allermeisten haben sich unglaublich
angestrengt haben investitionen auch
gemacht und haben irgendwie konzepte
umgesetzt im bereich der hygiene damit
sie diesen betrieb möglichst sicher
weiterführen können so aber es ist
genauso jetzt wie vor schwierig ist sagt
kurz gefasst es müssen schlicht wie
kontakte reduziert werden aber nochmal
der wird möchte ich wissen darf er
wieder mal so handeln weil sich bei die
frage ist es einmal jahrhundert können
sie verliert schon zu lachen sie
vermittelten vergleichen da diese nicht
einmal wieder geöffnet wird also
blattmann freizeit übrig und wir haben
größtes interesse daran dass wir nach
diesem november wieder in eine zeit
kommen wo man auch lockerungen machen
kann das ist das ziel genau deswegen
kommt jetzt auch dieser verkleinerte
shutdown aber wir können allerdings
nicht versprechen wie es im dezember aus
schaut also das heißt es da und kann
weitergehen
das hängt sehr stark vom
infektionsgeschehen ab die maßnahme die
wir jetzt ergreifen sollten helfen
ich bin froh übrigens dass die fdp in
den ländern das ja auch so sieht sonst
hätte er ja etwas anderes ergriffen nein
ort sankt marien sony in den ländern mit
ich habe gar kein problem wenn man eine
weise werden wir uns einig sind unseriös
präsident wenn eigentlich einig sind
dass wir kontakte reduzieren müssen dann
müssen wir auch diejenigen bereiche
definieren wo das eben jetzt geht das
hat priorisierungen zur folge
kitas schule sind prioritär bleiben
andere bereiche übrig jetzt zu sagen das
müsste man alles nicht machen
das führt zum größtmöglichen problem
nämlich dass das infektionsgeschehen
weiterhin dynamisch ansteigen kann und
das wollen wir beide nicht und deswegen
glaube ich muss man auch ehrlicherweise
vertreten dass das unangenehme maßnahmen
sind dass das von allen unglaublich viel
abverlangt dass es aber notwendige
maßnahmen sind und wir wollen dass wir
im ende november in eine lage kommen
dass man das alles wieder lockern kann
abschließende versprechungen kann da
niemand geben
sie haben gerade auch gesehen und gehört
was dieser wird gesagt hat und für viele
menschen ist es jetzt ja auch wichtig
für die zukunft zu planen deswegen auf
meine frage an sie können sie
versprechen dass es dann ab erster
dezember auch wieder losgeht
wichtig ist dass wir jetzt diese
maßnahmen alle angst nehmen
und ich glaube da ist sehr die
solidarität aller gefragt also das heißt
auch eben keine privaten feiern jetzt zu
veranstalten damit wir am ersten
dezember wieder loslegen kann
aber wer jetzt ganz klar zu 100 prozent
sagt das virus ist jetzt am 30 november
total im griff
der flug hat die leute an das macht auch
keine arbeit mehr fahren sage ich ganz
klar jeder und auch ob man in der
opposition ist oder in der regierung ist
auf sicht und das wirklich klar sagen
das gehört zur ehrlichkeit ja dazu und
man kann ja alles mögliche kritisieren
aber wenn man keine besseren vorschläge
da würde ich gerne machen haben wir uns
doch mal die die angst die lage ist an
das ginge ja auch an denen an den
wirklich zum teil viel strengeren
maßnahmen in unseren nachbarländern wir
wollen ja dass wir wieder zu einem leben
zurückkehren können wo eben nicht die
sorge mitschwingt sind die
intensivbetten belegt oder nicht und wir
alle wissen doch selbst wenn wir jetzt
noch intensivbetten haben die frei sind
das personal muss dazu auch da sein und
wenn wir jetzt die kontakte die wir
jetzt haben nur halbieren würden würden
wir bei den infektionsgeschehen bleiben
wo wir jetzt sind wir wollen aber weiter
kommen und wir wollen dass dieses land
mit kraft weitergehen kann und deshalb
halte ich die maßnahmen für hart aber
für angemessen und gut begründet und
insofern erstaunlich im übrigen auch
alexander dobrindt zu ich komme ja aus
rheinland-pfalz und in rheinland pfalz
gibt es einen stellvertretenden
ministerpräsidenten der bisher nicht
schwerer widersprochen hat in dieser
landesregierung der grad der fdp an
diesem übrigen aber im und fdp
generalsekretär
und da sieht man eben auch wenn man
gefragt ist etwas zu tun um die
bevölkerung zu schützen dann muss man
auch dazu stehen auch wenn es vielleicht
unangenehm ist und deshalb ist es
richtig dass wir beschlossen haben den
betrieben wie ohne dass sie
sie haben was zu schulden kommen lassen
wir schließen müssen dass wir ihnen
helfen mit 75 prozent es gibt
flexibilität für die betriebe die später
als vergangenen november geöffnet haben
oder für solo selbstständige und da sage
ich ganz klar dass eine große
kraftanstrengung dass unser alter
solidarität gefragt und ich kann die
gastronomen verstehen ihr unwohlsein
aber deshalb müssen wir auch solidarisch
sein und ihnen auch helfen ihr herr
linder wenn sie das hören glauben sie
dass am ersten dezember wieder geöffnet
wird oder kommt der dritte lockte das
kann jetzt niemand seriös sagen aber wir
müssen jetzt sprechen über die möglichen
alternativen um es mal klar zu sagen
frau klöckner erzählt jun wahrheit in
rheinland-pfalz wenn es nach der fdp
ginge bliebe die gastronomie offen
und dafür hat auch unser
stellvertretender ministerpräsident dort
geworben wir haben nur eben keine
absolute mehrheit sondern arbeiten in
koalitionen und ich lassen die hier
gerne vorwerfen dass wir uns nicht
durchsetzen können aber dennoch sagen
was eigentlich notwendig wäre und ich
nehm zweiten punkt vom frau klöckner auf
sie sagt ja es gebe ja keine alternative
oder man würde keine alternative
benennen ich gebe den vorwurf zurück es
gibt gegenwärtig keine offene klare
diskussion über die alternativen im
gegenteil es wird der eindruck erweckt
die jetzige krisenstrategie hätte keine
alternative und das überzeugt mich nicht
es gibt eine reihe auch von namhaften
persönlichkeiten die andere vorschläge
unterbreitet haben
es läuft darauf hinaus dass insbesondere
die menschen bei denen ein schwerer
krankheitsverlauf zu befürchten ist und
die dann auch die intensivbetten belegen
würden dass wir die in besonderer weise
schützen
das sind ältere menschen die in
pflegeeinrichtungen sind bis hin zu
menschen die jetzt zu hause leben wo wir
nachbarschaftshilfe organisieren können
und das wäre die eigentliche nationale
kraftanstrengung die nationale
kraftanstrengung liegt nicht darin alles
zu zumachen und dann schulden
aufzunehmen das irgendwie zu
kompensieren die nationale
kraftanstrengung wäre die besonders
schutzbedürftigen die besonders
gefährdeten in ganz besonderer weise ins
zentrum zu stellen
darüber hinaus dafür zu sorgen dass wir
in unserem lande regionale geht man
falls harte maßnahmen ergreifen
inklusive auch der schließung etwa von
solchen illegalen partys da würde ich
übrigens auch die gäste mit in anspruch
nehmen und auch denen ein bußgeld und
ich mit dem veranstalter zumuten und
diejenigen die darüber hinaus sagen ich
halte es für verantwortbar als mensch
ohne vorerkrankung am öffentlichen leben
teilzunehmen aber wir sollen das kann
deshalb meine frage wenn wir mit der
strategie weitermachen wie wir sie jetzt
erleben
aus ihrer sicht müssen wir dann mit
einem dritten vierten fünften locken
rechnen aber selbstverständlich müssen
wir das weil das virus wird noch da sein
ein impfstoff wird es nicht geben jetzt
brechen wir eine welle dann kommen die
menschen weihnachten und über neujahr
zusammen da kann man doch daran fühlen
wenn sie sich grundlegend etwas
verändert hat das dann
selbstverständlich wieder fallzahlen
steigen könnten dann sind wir in
derselben situation wie jetzt wenig so
wenigstens sollte den november jetzt
genutzt werden dass wir meinetwegen auch
parteiübergreifend einmal darüber
sprechen was können wir tun um das land
wieder zu öffnen und öffentliches
kulturelles wirtschaftliches leben zu
ermöglichen das soll noch nicht eine
parteipolitische frage werden warum holt
die regierung immer nur die einen
experten und warum spricht ziemlich auch
mit den anderen experten den streiks den
schmid keiner sitzt dieser welt wenn der
chef der bundesvereinigung der kassen
ärzte der kassenärztlichen
bundesvereinigung sich äußert das ist ja
kein laie der spricht für alle
niedergelassenen ärztinnen und ärzte in
deutschland
das können politiker nicht einfach so
vom tisch wischen sprechen sie zu viel
mit herrn thorsten und zu wenig mit den
streger druck nein aber die
argumentation erweckt er jetzt einen
vollkommen falschen eindruck nämlich aus
richtung ein paar wenige um ein paar
wenige besonders gefährdete handeln die
man halt schützen muss wenn man sich die
situation in deutschland anschaut und
unsere gesellschaft und die über 65
jährigen die noch mal besonders
gefährdet sind diejenigen mit
vorerkrankungen die nun mal besonders
gefertigt sind wenn man die alle
zusammennimmt dann reden wir von einem
drittel der gesellschaft und bei einem
drittel der gesellschaft dass sie
besonders schützen wollen das kann man
halt nur dann tun indem alle dann auch
eine bereitschaft erklären etwas weniger
an kontakten zu haben nur dann
funktioniert der schutz in unserer
gesellschaft der besonders betroffenen
den
eindruck zu erwecken man könnte das mit
23 lieferungen voraus irgendwie
hinkriegen das ist schlichtweg falsch
und deswegen stehen einmal ich möchte
ihn mit denen wir auch reden die gegner
der aktuellen politik sind die sagen am
schluss ihr müsst die kontakte
reduzieren sie sagen das ist ein anderer
stelle jetzt zu machen und wir sagen
wenn wir schule nicht wollen kita nicht
wollen das wirtschaftsleben nicht unter
die leitung dieser bereich aber den
punkt wären wir ja eine meinung dass wir
die kontakte reduzieren dass man nur zu
fünft beispielsweise sich trifft nur
zwei haushalte da ist ja gar nicht der
dissens
das kann ja dann durchaus weiter
fortgesetzt werden aber darüber hinaus
muss das möglich sein
darum haben wir gestatten sie mir eins
zu sagen hier wurde eben eingeblendet
mein zitat die regierung spricht mit den
falschen experten das ist nicht mein
zitat so möchte ich nicht zitiert sein
die regierung muss auch mit anderen
experten sprechen habe ich es wird mit
allen experten gesprochen ist sagte
schwesig
was sollen da wird die spree frau
schwesig der international anerkannte
epidemiologe klaus stöhr warnt in diesem
wochenende in der welt ich zitiere in
vier wochen werden wir immer noch 80
prozent der deutschen für das virus voll
empfänglich sein wenn wir dann den fuß
von der bremse nehmen wird die pandemie
mit vollem schwung wieder einsetzen
warum wiegt die politik die bürger in
falscher sicherheit dann mit aussicht
auf eine rückkehr zur normalität im
dezember ich habe nicht den eindruck
dass wir die bevölkerung in falscher
sicherheit weniger im gegenteil wir
machen die auch schon seit wochen darauf
aufmerksam gerade was die größeren
familienfeiern an geht das
alles großes problem ist dass wir haben
als idee und das haben mehrere experten
entwickelt ist zu sagen wir müssen jetzt
diese dynamik rausnehmen weil wir
ansonsten in ein notfall laufen in den
fall dass und drei wochen zum beispiel
die intensiv kapazitäten dicht sein
können denn man muss ich noch mal vor
augen führen es ist ein unterschied ob
jemand zum beispiel wegen cobit beatmet
werden muss das kann bis zu drei wochen
dauern
im gegensatz zu einer anderen schweren
erkrankung wo sich schon nach vier oder
fünf tagen entscheidet schafft es der
patient oder nicht und deswegen laufen
sukzessive diese kapazitäten voll und
die frage ist die frage was ist dann im
dezember ist berechtigt wir haben aber
im frühjahr einen guten eine gute
erfahrung damit gemacht
die sachen zu schließen das ist ein
shutdown kein lockdown ich mir sind die
begriffe egal ich nur deutlich machen es
gibt keine ausgangssperre sowie in
anderen ländern
und wir haben früher gute erfahrungen
macht zu schließen und dann die dinge
unter schutzmaßnahmen zu öffnen und
darüber wir müssen uns anschauen und 14
tagen wie es die bürger dieses
wellenbrecher shutdowns und wie ist das
dann im dezember möglich heute ist schon
klar das verspricht auch keiner dass man
sicherlich nicht eine silvesterparty
feiern kann wie wir das eben von der
sogenannten halloween party erlebt haben
das ist schon mal klar aber das was sie
verhindern wollen ist dass wir
weihnachten die situation wie ostern
haben dass man nicht mal seine eltern
besuchen
und ein wort zu den gastronomen es ist
total hart ich will da noch mal zurück
und wir kennen die situation der
gastronom weil wir selber mit ihm im
gespräch sind
und worum es uns geht als regierung zehn
milliarden euro nehmen wir in die hand
um bis zu 75 prozent des umsatzes aus
einem guten monat november 19
bereitzustellen und wir als land in
fouling zum beispiel noch einmal auf die
75 prozent 5 prozent drauf dass sie auf
80 kommen in der gastronomie also wir
versuchen auch mit großen mitteln zu
helfen und zum vorschlag von herrn
lindner die risikogruppen oder die
älteren besser zu schützen na ja ehrlich
gesagt diese strategie verfolgen wir
längst es ist längst so dass die
besuchsrechte zum beispiel für
pflegeheime viel eingegrenzte sind das
ist aber auch eine hohe belastung für
die älteren die dort sind und schwer
sich strings die sprechen im gesundheits
und pflegebereich mehr testen das machen
wir schon aber die alten einzusperren
damit die jungen
in restaurants gehen können das wird
auch nicht funktionieren auch schwierig
sie sprechen einen weg an über den wir
morgen auch in der bild zeitung
berichten und zwar ist das der op von
tübingen der das als erste stadt so
genannte schweden regeln einführen will
das ist die seite 2 der bild zeitung von
morgen und zwar wie palmer möchte in
diesem zusammenhang die alten besser
schützen er möchte dafür sorgen dass die
älteren zu bestimmten einkaufszeiten
rausgehen und dass sie nicht mehr busse
benutzen möglichst fahrrad fahren oder
im sammel taxi unterwegs sind und das
ist das zitat er sagt der tübinger
appell setzt wie schweden auf
eigenverantwortung und besonderen schutz
der alten herr dobrindt kann das modell
für deutschland sagen da kann man sich
ja mal schweden anschauen wenn das das
öl das das ist was der oberbürgermeister
hier will in schweden die zahlen heißen
dass genau eine generation nämlich die
ältere die lasten dieser politik zu
tragen hat wenn man stockholm und
münchen miteinander vergleicht pro
100000 einwohner sind in stockholm 16
mal so viele menschen verstorben wie in
münchen aber da gibt es ja eine
statistik da geht es ja um die statistik
gut aber für die politik sich weder
sagen sie hätten jetzt daraus gelernt
weil sie sagen dass sie sozusagen alten
und pflegeheime jetzt besser schützen
und deswegen auf mehr eigenverantwortung
setzen können lindner ist das modell was
der thüringer oberbürgermeister tübinger
oberbürgermeister fährt was sind für
ganz deutschland vorstellt ich rate ab
davon dass wir uns mit schweden
vergleichen das modell schweden ist in
deutschland politisch argumentativ
verbrannt die schweden haben auch fehler
gemacht sich korrigiert also der
schweden sagt meint völlig
unterschiedliche dinge aber ich halte es
ebenfalls für richtig dass wir um das
wort von frau merkel noch einmal
aufzunehmen eine nationale
kraftanstrengung organisieren mit allem
was wir an ressourcen und kreativität
haben die menschen die schutzbedürftig
sind so zu schützen dass sie nicht
vereinsamen
das bedeutet etwa die tests strategie
des bbu
das in allen ländern umsetzen bis ins
einzelne pflegeheim damit die
pflegekräfte und die reinigungskräfte
fortwährend getestet werden von da wird
nämlich das virus eingeschleppt dass
gleichzeitig der die besten masken zur
verfügung stehen ffw zwei masken für
alle die dort ein und aus gehen also
sportschützen in der nachbarschaft
schützen und selbstverständlich müssen
wir uns als sie immer war auch
zurücknehmen es geht nicht um partys es
geht sehr wohl auch um kontakt
beschränkungen eine wenige leute einige
wenige leute vielleicht auch nur zwei
haushalte aber zumindest muss es eine
strategie sein die durch haltbar ist und
ich weiß nicht die sie modell geheime
werden das war ein bis zwei kolleginnen
und der kollege stimmen vielleicht zu
oder auch nicht so wie wir das jetzt
machen das können wir doch nicht bis
februar märz nächsten jahres durchhalten
bis wir einen impfstoff haben und da sag
ja nicht nur ich sondern es sind über 30
bürgermeister von cdu spd und anderen
parteien also über 30 oberbürgermeister
aus allen parteien haben einen
dringenden appell geäußert das
bitteschön gastronomie das beherbergung
dass kultur offenbaren das ist nicht nur
eine fdp thema sondern die menschen die
in den städten verantwortung tragen quer
über alle parteien über 30
oberbürgermeister richten den appell an
euch gemeinsam sollten wir doch das
ernst nehmen also ich war mal wenn ich
muss ihm über christian ich muss dir
sagen was wir nicht durchhalten
in den letzten 14 tagen haben sich die
belegungen der intensivbetten in
deutschland verdoppelt die nächsten 14
tagen der verdoppelung und die 14 tage
darauf eine verdoppelung und wir sind
über dem was wir an intensivbetten zur
verfügung haben das halten wir nicht
durch und weil das und müssen in der
formel 1 das ist das minimum mit dem mit
dem wir jetzt arbeiten lassen
und da widerspreche ich jawohl wir
halten das mit der verdoppelung der
belegung nicht durch deshalb müssen wir
maßnahmen ergreifen die begrenzung der
persönlichen kontakte die reduzierung
auf zwei haushalte einverstanden das ist
ein wirksames mittel
die schutzkonzepte in den
pflegeeinrichtungen die sind noch alles
andere als optimal
da würde ich sagen hält die
argumentation wir tun da schon alles
extrem auf einer party einer praktischen
überprüfen können wir gerne mal für
schnelltests finanziell ein angebot ist
zusammen mit der bild besuchen wir fünf
pflegeeinrichtungen und fragen mal wie
das in der praxis läuft etwas besser
werden kann wenn du es machst einer
sicherheit besser werden ich bin auf
jeden fall ansteuern sollten wir das bei
aber dann schauen wir auch an was den
letzten monaten einverstanden aber
gastronomie hotellerie museen also
museum zu schließen
also das sind die bereiche wo doch genau
nachgeschaut werden kann wer geht also
doch noch einige rote kreuz sondern auch
im protokoll also sie gehen gemeinsam
mit herrn lindner und uns durch die
pflegeheime und schauen sich das an
er ist sofort ja keine frage weil wir
auch sehen wollen natürlich was kann man
auch besser machen aber wir schauen auch
an was mit der zeit alles gemacht haben
interessant ist doch nur die
argumentation immer zu sagen oh mein
gott was kommt noch alles im
dezember/januar wir können das doch
alles über solange nicht aushalten und
gleichzeitig zu sagen dass man
eigentlich viel weniger haben will
also entweder ja es ist so wenig dass
wir so lange vor uns noch her tragen
müssen dass wir wieder nicht zurück
können verstehe ich nicht ganz einfach
wenn das was wir jetzt tun
zu viel ist ja dass wir es im dezember
im januar im februar noch einmal
verschärfen müssen das sind ja deine
befürchtungen nein dann kannst du auch
damals sah ich sagen da alle fest was
wir jetzt schon machen du nicht haben
leid meinte man sich entscheiden meine
befohlen wird den schutz der bevölkerung
jetzt ja oder sagen wir es hatten noch
ein bisschen zeit also das sind schein
alternativen ich will auch den schutz
der bevölkerung ich glaube nur dass die
maßnahmen nicht wirksam sind das die
wirksamen maßnahmen verlängert werden
können einverstanden nur die unwirksame
maßnahmen sollten die eben nicht
verlängern und ich bleib dabei
gastronomie zu schließen das ist eine
unwirksame maßnahmen deshalb den
anwälten
ich weiß noch einmal frau schwesig mit
ins gespräch schwesig wir haben heute
auch ein sehr dramatischen appell des
saarländischen ministerpräsidenten
wörter in der bild am sonntag vor einem
kollaps der kliniken gewarnt und hat
gesagt das könnte schon bald so weit
sein sie sind ministerpräsidenten von
mecklenburg vorpommern wie sieht es in
ihren kliniken aus und teilen sie diese
einschätzung dass wir da vor einem
kollaps stehen könnten
schon in naher zukunft wir machen genau
diese harten maßnahmen weil wir die
sorge haben dass das in den nächsten
wochen droht sonst würden wir ja nicht
so ne kasten maßnahmen machen
es muss ja niemand denken dass wir das
selber gut finden oder dass wir selber
sagen hurra wir schließen jetzt was es
ist so wie der ministerpräsident und
saarland sagt und in meinem bundesland
ist die lage in den kliniken noch besser
weil wir das bundesland sind von anfang
an mit den geringsten infektionen das
sieht man dann natürlich auch in den
klinikbetten aber wir haben jetzt
insgesamt in deutschland eine hohe
dynamik und auch für den norden macht
das nicht teilt und ich will noch mal
darauf hinweisen dass es jetzt schon so
ist dass operationen dann wieder
zurückgestellt werden und wir gucken
hier immer nur auf diejenigen die
medizinische behandlung brauchen für
kurve der schlaganfall den herzinfarkt
die krebserkrankung all das gibt es
leider trotz kurve und auch die menschen
haben ein recht auf eine gute
medizinische versorgung und deswegen
kann ich nur wirklich alle jetzt bitten
es kommt auf jeden und jeden einzelnen
im november und umso mehr geht im
november schaffen umso mehr nehmen wir
die dynamik aus diesen drohenden
gesundheitsnotstand raus vor schlüssig
man hört jetzt immer mehr das eigentlich
nicht das problem ist die fehlende
betten sondern vor allem das personal
also dass es nicht genügend personal
gibt dafür die beatmungsgeräte zb zu
bedienen haben sie versäumt da genügend
personal auszubilden
nein aber so eine ausbildung wird auch
nicht in ein paar monaten gemacht das
ist ein hoher anspruch intensivpflege
und viele bundesländer haben da jetzt
auch einiges verbessert wir haben sogar
studiengänge jetzt dafür werden dafür
eingeführt aber das machen sie nicht
alles in ein paar monaten und so zu tun
als ob wir könnten so weitermachen
hauptsache wir haben genug betten und
personal und das könnte man alles in
monaten organisieren
das ist ein irrglaube deutschland ist
schon das land mit super gut
qualifizierten personal mit den meisten
betten aber auch das ist endlich und wir
haben menschen gerade bei einer älteren
bevölkerung deswegen ist deutschland
hier auch besonders bedroht wir haben
viele ältere menschen wo natürlich auch
andere schwere erkrankungen zum beispiel
der herzinfarkt droht und deshalb man
kann es nicht mit der die eine sache mit
der anderen auf rechnen die sachen sind
endlich und wir müssen jetzt die
prioritäten setzen
frau klöckner sie sind ministerin im
kabinett sie sind bei allen sitzungen
dabei kennen alle zahlen wie viel angst
haben sie persönlich in diesen wochen
wenn sie sagen das und wenn sie hören
dass es ein kollaps geben könnte in den
kliniken angst würde leben und zu
schlechten entscheidungen führen ich hab
sorge und in dieser sorge bin ich wie
auch viele meiner kolleginnen und
kollegen oder allem einer kabinetts
kolleginnen und kollegen sehr aufmerksam
und nehmen es auch sehr sehr ernst und
uns geht es nicht um eine schnelle
schlagzeile uns geht es nicht um
parteipolitik sondern uns geht es darum
dass wir die lage im griff haben und
auch einmal wenn wir uns das benachbarte
ausland anschauen sehen werden wie gut
wir bisher durch diese krise gekommen
sind aber wir haben keine gewähr dafür
dass wir so weitermachen wie bisher wir
haben nachgeschaut wir haben viele land
innerhalb dieses jahres und innerhalb
dieses jahres warten wissen wir auch wo
wieder welche stellschrauben auftreten
aber wir haben auch gesehen als er das
dann doch relativ unbekümmert dann auch
verbracht worden ist dass er jedem gut
getan hat erst einmal
das mitnichten nach dem sommerferien
alles wieder so ist wie vorher
und insofern sage ich nicht angst ist
das was uns umtreiben sollte wir sollten
auch keine panik aber verantwortungsvoll
sollten sie sagen ich soll sagen könne
sie sagen man sollte keine panik schön
gleichzeitig erleben wir dass die
bundeskanzlerin fast jeden tag zitiert
wird mit neuen äußerungen jeder tag
zählt die lage ist dramatisch das sind
ja schon dinge die bei der bevölkerung
eher fürsorge sorgen oder nicht ja aber
es gibt einen unterschied zwischen sorge
und zwischen panik also
kinder wissen dass wenn ihre eltern
besorgt sein bis das was anderes als
wenn sie panisch treten also insofern
uns hat nichts mit eltern und kindern zu
tun dass politik und bevölkerung damit
vergleichen will aber nur uns zu
verdeutlichen
es gibt einen unterschied zwischen sorge
und auch mahnende worte zu finden und es
mahnende worte auch notwendig sind wir
sehen wir doch allein wenn sie durch
berlin gehen als als wären wir zum teil
in einigen stadtteilen auf einem anderen
planeten als gäbe es anscheinend krone
nicht oder man hätte nicht mitbekommen
das ist corinna gibt ich selbst habe
erlebt dass ich mit maske in einem
restaurant kam und ein wirt zu mir sagte
ich bräuchte ja keine maske rich doch
sie im übrigen auch also diese sorge ist
nicht panik sondern wiesemann
es hat ja etwas damit zu tun dass wir
auch solidarisch sind jetzt zahlen ja
ganz viele die sich ordentlich verhalten
haben die auch alle regeln eingehalten
haben zahlen jetzt den ice für
diejenigen mit die vieles ignoriert
haben und deshalb noch einmal von einer
kanzlerin und von einer bundesregierung
erwartet man klar erwartet man führung
und auch eben von den
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten und dass das in so
großer eigentlichkeit beschlossen worden
ist mit großer sorge auf wohlwissend
egal welcher partei angehört wohl wissen
dass das auch harte einschränkungen sind
zb für gastronom
aber diese hatten einschränkungen jetzt
zumachen kalkuliert zu machen und
befristet zu machen ist
die bessere alternative als dann in
etwas reinzulaufen wo überhaupt nicht
mehr eine lage im griff ist und wir dann
wie im benachbarten ausland sogar
ausgangssprache hätten und das wollen
wir nicht wir wollen weder in
privatwohnungen kontrollieren noch
wollen wir eine komplette ausgangssperre
sondern wirklich mit augenmaß das war
harte entscheidungen treffen aber die so
zu treffen dass sie auch wieder ein ende
haben können herr lindner sind wir hier
in berlin so wie vor klöckner ist
formuliert auf einem anderen planeten
oder sind die menschen einfach nicht
mehr zu zügeln
das ist ja das wort was die kanzlerin
immer ich zitiere die kanzlerin nicht
verallgemeinern ich habe den stadtteilen
waren okay dann in stadtteilen auf einem
anderen kunden jetzt thematisieren wie
wie nehmen sie das war ja der hat julia
klöckner rechts das gilt aber nicht nur
für berlin sondern auch für andere
großstädte das in teilen menschen
verantwortungslos sind das ist junge
menschen gibt die partys feiern dass es
besorgnisse gibt ja es gibt auch
massenhaft große hochzeiten wo die
teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmer nicht
klar nachgehalten werden wir
ordnungsbehörden berichten dass man sich
auch regelrecht widersetzt der
nachverfolgung von infektionsketten all
das gibt und ich glaube da haben wir
miteinander einen großen konsens
ich glaube auch nicht nur unter den
parteien sondern in der ganz großen
mehrheit unserer gesellschaft dass wir
das nicht hinnehmen wollen weil hier
einige nicht nur sich selbst gefährden
sondern uns alle
ja in gefahr bringen und das muss
unterbunden werden mit allen
möglichkeiten die das ordnungsrecht
bietet das gleiche gilt für sie und
nicht wir machen jetzt keine großen
partys aber wir können eben jetzt auch
nicht fünf haushalte zusammen bringen
bei uns in der wohnung sondern müssen
uns da auch jeweils reduzieren eine
zeitlang zügel ich glaube da gibt es
einen großen konsens und von dem
ausgehend muss man prüfen welche
maßnahmen ist vielleicht ehrlich und gut
gemeint aber am ende nicht wirksam
und genau diese debatte muss auch
geführt werden weil wir dann zu besseren
ergebnissen kommen und war nach meiner
festen überzeugung die einschränkungen
von freiheit von den menschen nur dann
mitgeteilt
fragen werden wenn sie sehen dass das in
einer harten argumentativen
auseinandersetzung erfolgt wo auch
wirklich wissenschaftlich evident
begründet wird was ja viel zu wenig
berichtet worden ist ist etwa dass bei
dem beschluss der bund länder runde
immerhin ist eine protokollnotiz gibt
der mann entnehmen kann dass zumindest
einer der teilnehmer hinsichtlich auch
der wissenschaftlichen begründetheit
einiger maßnahmen zweifel angemeldet hat
das war nur eine protokollnotiz zeigt
aber wie offensichtlich dort auch
gerungen werden musste um einzelne
maßnahmen
frau schwesig könnte mal berichten wie
die auseinandersetzung war
beispielsweise bei der frage im handel
sollen zehn oder 25 quadratmeter pro
person im handel zur verfügung stehen
also einvernehmen ist gut aber ich
glaube es ist auch für demokratie kein
schaden wenn sichtbar wird dass dinge
unterschiedlich gesehen würden und dass
alternativen gibt
so wurde noch mal hand aufs herz wenn
sie jetzt die in die nächsten wochen
schauen haben sie da wirklich das gefühl
dass wir mit diesen maßnahmen die wellen
brechen und dann alles anders wird und
wir weihnachten zumindest in anderer
form feiern können als wir das jetzt im
november können aber es mangelt nicht an
wissenschaftlicher begleitung gerade in
den letzten monaten haben wir ja so viel
beratung gehabt wie selten zuvor
zumindest was die medizinischen fragen
angeht
und deswegen ist es richtig sich auf der
einen seite auf die wissenschaftliche
begleitung zu stützen auf der anderen
seite war festzustellen dass die auch
sehr unterschiedlich ausfallen kann und
die politik muss entscheiden und es
genau hier passiert die politik hat
einen maßnahmenkatalog entschieden von
dem wir ausgehen und das bestätigen ja
auch ein großteil der wissenschaftler
dass das die welle brechen kann
zumindestens die dynamik umkehren kann
und wie das dann im dezember weiter geht
es hängt auch sehr stark von der frage
ab wie schaut die situation in den
krankenhäusern aus wie stehen die
patienten betten zur verfügung all das
wird man in einem gesamtsystem noch
einmal bewerten müssen um dann zu
weiteren ergebnisse aber wenn es dann
aber wenn ist was eine wende hin welche
sich oder einer deutlich seine fragen
wenn die zahlen sich nicht wirklich
ändern also wenn sie zahlen nicht
runtergehen
die bei uns ist kein game und und es
kann also nicht die menschen
die zahlen werden rund tag und wenn es
aber gleichzeitig kein impfstoff gibt
was machen wir dann das system mehr die
mehrheit der wissenschaftler sagt dass
diese maßnahmen notwendig sind und
möglicherweise noch mehr notwendig ist
und man hätte ja das ein oder andere
sogar zusätzlich gefordert von der
politik jetzt aber man hat sich auf
diese priorität jetzt entsprechend
vereinbaren können und was im dezember
ist das heißt die schöne und
einzelhandel dran möglicherweise heute
kann ihnen niemand sagen ob im dezember
in einer situation stehen bei der wir
weil die zahlen runter gehen das ist
unsere hoffnung wieder lockern können
das ist das was wir politisch wollen
oder um in einer situation sind wo man
stärker maßnahmen wie wir sie in den
ländern um uns herum in europa auch
sehen also aus sondern als ausgangs
verschränkung rechtlich können jetzt in
frankreich auch wenn man sieht was alles
möglich ist in den anderen ländern wir
wollen das ausdrücklich nicht deswegen
haben wir deutlich früher als die
anderen länder um uns herum maßnahmen
ergriffen
ich habe das auch deutlich gesagt dass
wir diskutiert haben im deutschen
bundestag und wir haben den letzten
monaten ja oft darüber diskutiert im
parlament dass wir den weg den
beispielsweise frankreich gegangen ist
zuwarten 10.000 15.000 20.000 40.000
infektionen pro tag wo dat erst
maßnahmen ergreifen dass wir den nicht
gehen wollte und deswegen frühzeitig
dazu uns entschlossen haben jetzt diesen
teil lockdown zu organisieren vor
schwierig wie nehmen sie das wahr und
können sie versprechen dass zum beispiel
die schulen offen bleiben werden
definitiv das kann niemand versprechen
was wir sagen können ist dass wir uns
genau für diese anderen maßnahmen jetzt
entschieden haben
ziel kitas und schulen offen zu halten
denn wir haben ja aus dem frühjahr etwas
gelernt
wir haben gelernt dass die schließung
von kitas und schulen ein ganz harter
schritt ist der betrifft die bildung der
kinder er betrifft die vereinbarkeit er
trifft auch die wirtschaft hat weil
viele fachkräfte dann gar nicht arbeiten
können und wir haben auch gelernt dass
dieses komplette schließen der
pflegeheime gar keine besuche auch weder
für die pflegekräfte noch für die
bewohner geht und das sind jetzt zwei
dinge die wir offen halten wollen bei
allen schwierigkeiten grad kita schule
und pflegeheime haben ihre
herausforderung und deswegen müssen wir
eben in den maßnahmen in den anderen
maßnahmen strenger sein was ist wenn die
bälle nicht gebrochen wird die welle hat
genau der wellenbrecher hat genau das
ziel das man kita und schule offen
halten kann
ich schlage vor wir müssen uns jetzt
darauf konzentrieren und november
diese maßnahmen sehr hart durchzuziehen
das ist die einen marathon und wir sind
schon eine ganze zeit unterwegs aber
jetzt ist es als ob man nochmal so ein
berg hoch laufen muss und dann ist meine
hoffnung dass wir im dezember wieder
dinge öffnen können natürlich keine
großen familienveranstaltung
familienfeiern das glaube ich sieht man
jetzt schon und was ich wichtig halte
wir brauchen dann ganz harte regeln darf
was machen wir wenn einzelne kleinere
gebiete noch nicht so weit sind es ist
ein fehler in den letzten vier wochen
passiert es gab keine bereitschaft zu
sagen dort wo die ersten risikogebiete
entstanden sind härtere einschnitte zu
machen was bedeutet das für härtere
einschnitte schön wie davor ein beispiel
ein beispiel vor 14 tagen habe ich dafür
geworben und daniel günther dass man zb
reisen aus risikogebieten die eine hohe
inzidenz haben einschränkt mindestens
mit einer test flicht belegt das ist der
heiß diskutiert worden da sind wir und
sie sind krank und gestaltern mit diesen
vorschlag muss man sagen es ist beklagt
und gerichte gerichte es ist gut dass es
im rechtsstaat alles überprüft und ich
sage nur was wir heute haben vor 14
tagen wollten wir weniger
einschränkungen als sie heute notwendig
sind und das wäre doch gut auch aus
diesen sachen zu lernen
frau schwesig spricht das beherbergungs
verbot an was dann und den gerichten
gespräche noch über meer
ich glaube frau schwesig spricht über
ein ausreiseverbot das damals diskutiert
worden ist das wäre zum beispiel in
berlin lebt dass der die stadtgrenzen
nicht verlassen darf das war seinerzeit
in der mission nein das war dann muss
man die stelle widersprechen bitte dann
sagen sie doch was diesmal sprechen wird
ziemlich auf medienbericht habe ich
ganze hier richtig stellen was wir
wollten deine günther und ich haben eine
pk vorgeschlagen dass wir für
risikogebiete die eine hohe incidents
haben zum beispiel diese tests pflicht
lassen zb für touristische reisen
was wir so und das ist jetzt nicht
durchgegangen jetzt dürfte es gar keine
reisen mehr geben in deutschland ist
doch ein viel härterer eingriff sie
selber haben vorhin vorgeschlagen herr
lindner dass man maßnahmen braucht
vielleicht wäre es besser gewesen vor
vier wochen die maßnahmen die jetzt für
ganz deutschland kommen in einzelne
gebiete zu verhängen die schon sehr
dynamischen anstatt es wieder ganz
deutschland trifft und ich glaube dass
wir uns vor dieser diskussion nicht
drücken können
bevor wir bevor wir darüber
weiterdiskutiert würdig und geschehene
einmal zeigen was deutsche urlauber und
hoteliers darüber denken was frau
schwesig angesprochen hat und für viele
ist das reisen ja extrem schwierig
geworden wir haben uns umgehört in der
lübecker bucht urlauber raus und das
ausgerechnet hier mitten im tourismus
land schleswig holstein im schönen
ostseebad scharbeutz lockdown nummer
zwei heißt hier auch knallhart werk ein
schleswig-holsteiner ist und eigentlich
hier seinen ruhigen urlaub im herbst
sind verbringen wollte muss das land
verlassen
schön dass du da bist von wegen wir
haben gerne bis mittwoch problem was uns
sehr gut geführt andere hier vom wetter
her winkels auch aber der putter wir uns
ja lagers mit jungs wollte die regierung
hier in schleswig holstein
deutschland fährt also zum zweiten mal
runter und dabei sind auch touristische
reisen verboten deshalb werden
hunderttausende urlauber im eigenen land
praktisch rausgeschmissen das
verständnis der touristen gleich null
die hotels seien nicht der kommune
androht mich auf die lokal im grunde
alles sagen die rolle des schwarzen
peters übernehmen die hotelchefs sie
müssen die gäste schweren herzens
rausschmeißen sowie tanz haltermann er
hat durch die korona maßnahmen dieses
jahr schon 1,5 millionen euro verlust
gemacht hat sich aber dabei an alle
hygiene konzepte der bundesregierung
gehalten
wir haben ein konzept gefordert waren
weit über das geschuldete maß hinaus
umgesetzt und ich glaube dass es keine
notwendigkeit gab uns zu schließen
nun muss man mit der entscheidung leben
und das anderer zu sagen wir machen
jetzt das beste draus hoffen auf die
staatshilfen angekündigt sind dass man
uns unterstützt und wir bereiten uns auf
eine wiedereröffnung für anstelle von
goldenem herbsteiner küste heißt es
jetzt koffer packen und ab nach hause
herr dobrindt sie haben die beiden
rentner dort gesehen
erklären sie uns bitte mal wie gehen die
korona zahlen zurück wenn diese beiden
jetzt da raus geschmissen werden was
hilft es
na ja es geht hier nicht um die beiden
herum die vielzahl der beiden die
überall unterwegs sind im urlaub was
nachvollziehbar ist und was ja viele
auch gerne machen gerade auch in dieser
herbstzeit aber auch das trägt natürlich
zum infektionsgeschehen bei wir haben zb
ja gesehen dass das runterfahren
einzelne bereiche was wir gemacht haben
er hat das gerade land zum beispiel ein
landkreis runtergefahren als erkannt
wurde da ist ein hotspot andere bereiche
auch dass sich das virus weiter trägt in
ganz deutschland frau schwesig hat
zurecht mal darauf hingewiesen dass sie
in ihrem bundesland kaum infektionen hat
aber wenn dann natürlich reisende kommen
die infektionszahlen steigen und man das
relativ gut zurückführen kann
all das ist ein wesentlicher teil das
reisen das dazu
beiträgt dass sich infektionen verteilen
warum darf erst dadurch auch deutschland
meine eltern nicht mehr besuchen aber
ich darf europäisch verreisen wir haben
ja in ganz europa sehr unterschiedliche
regelungen inzwischen aber das verraten
doch wir haben doch wesentlich wir haben
wesentlich strengere regelungen in
anderen ländern in diese eben gerade auf
nachbarländer sind überhaupt nicht mehr
reisen dürfen geschweige der
griechenland dass sie das beispiel noch
fliegen sie können sie auch in unseren
nachbarländern versuchen da werden sie
es nicht schaffen dass sie da jetzt hin
fahren können zum teil und
übernachtungen noch zu buchen das hängt
sehr stark ab von der politik vor ort
das ist ja vollkommen klar wir selber
müssen größeres interesse daran haben
dass die nicht die infektionsgeschehen
die wir in anderen ländern schon
erkennen bei uns eintragen und das
entsprechend das sind und dass wir sein
bundesland jetzt eingesperrt wird und
künftig vielleicht auch in seiner
eigenen stadt nein dass das definitiv
nicht der fall
ich finde es nicht in ordnung dass man
eingesperrt wird auch nicht in seinem
eigenen bundesland aber es geht jetzt
darum die kontakte zu reduzieren und
deswegen müssen die nächsten vier wochen
auch die urlaubs kontakte entsprechend
reduziert werden deswegen ist es richtig
lindner wie nehmen sie das wahr wenn sie
da jetzt die rentner hören die früher
abreisen wollten das ehepaar wollte am
mittwoch erst fahren muss jetzt früher
weg bin nehmen sie das wahr herr uns
habe ich glaube darum kreist der ganze
abend hier
es gibt maßnahmen die sind wirksam um
kontakte zu reduzieren und das ist
wichtig um eine welle zu brechen und das
infektionsgeschehen unter kontrolle zu
halten und es gibt maßnahmen die werden
beschlossen und die tragen eben nicht
dazu bei dass wirklich die
infektionszahlen runtergehen und genau
diese debatte muss man aller
nüchternheit führen
wir haben das gemeinsame ziel wir wollen
die partie unter kontrolle halten
wir wollen die menschen schützen wir
wollen das gesundheitssystem vor
überlastung bewahren wollen nicht
schreckliche bilder sehen wir wollen
nicht entscheiden müssen wer kann und
muss behandelt werden und wer nicht das
wollen wir alles und dann muss man sehr
sorgfältig überlegen welche maßnahmen
ist dafür geeignet und welche nicht denn
schon das was wir jetzt an
beschränkungen haben werden wir nicht
durchhalten können bis zum märz des
nächsten jahres das im kulturellen und
wirtschaftlichen bereich es zu einem
irreparablen schaden kommt und das
gehört
ein krisen management natürlich auch mit
dazu gesundheitsschutz ist das eine ziel
und müssen auf der anderen seite schauen
welche maßnahmen dazu sind
verhältnismäßig so dass nicht neue
schäden entstehen denn auch wer seine
wirtschaftliche existenz verliert nimmt
nimmt schaden an der seele und erkrankt
möglicherweise vorsorge er muss das klug
ausbalanciert werden und vier wochen
jetzt diesen zweiten locker und
durchzuhalten das wird dieses land noch
mal schaffen aber das vier monate bis
ein impfstoff da ist da fehlt mir die
fantasie von klöckner ich möchte auch
mal zu ihnen kommen wenn wir jetzt die
hotelbesitzer dort sehen und es geht ja
den restaurantbesitzern hotelbesitzern
im ganzen land so die haben jetzt
massive ausnahme massive ausfälle
gleichzeitig übernimmt der staat bis zu
75 prozent aber das muss ja irgendwann
auch bezahlt werden glauben sie es kommt
so was wie ein corona soli irgendwann
olaf scholz hat schon steuererhöhungen
ins spiel gebracht also die frage an sie
wie wird das alles bezahlt sie haben ja
mehrere fragen gerade gestellt also zum
einen ob ich sie wie das bezahlt werden
soll und ob ein corona soli kommt oder
nicht zum einen will ich festhalten
hätten wir nicht so gut und auch so
verantwortungsvoll gewirtschaftet
dann könnte man jetzt nicht diesen maßen
an flankierend zur unterstützung
einleiten oder wie sie bereits
eingeleitet worden sind und insofern
glaube ich sollten wir das aus weder
klar auch sehr deutlich hier festhalten
das ist in anderen ländern europas
nichts unmögliches die wirtschaft so
flankierend gestützt werden kann gerade
weil die weil die wirtschaftsunternehmen
ihr nichts dafür können aber trotzdem
sicher irgendwann jemand bezahlt
entscheidung auch eingeschränkt sind und
insofern ist das was vorgesehen ist
über 200 milliarden euro wie wir ja in
die hand genommen haben natürlich muss
das ganze auch wieder mit einem soliden
abbau fahrt wieder abgetragen werden
genauso wie wir die voraussetzung
um geschafft haben dass wir überhaupt
toll zu helfen können ich glaube es ist
das falsche zeichen zu sagen jetzt muss
die bevölkerung ein corona solids 1
sie zahlt schon einen soli in vielfacher
form tourismus nicht in euro oder
cent-bereich sein sondern in vielfacher
form was ihr leben eben angelangt und
ich glaube das ist das einfachste
immerhin regierung plötzlich der
steuererhöhungen fordern weil darin geht
es um die tasche der bürgerinnen und
bürger die haben genug einschränkungen
sondern politik muss dann auch sparsam
sein muss die haushalte wie jetzt auch
gelegt werden die jetzt wollten auch
unter diesen neuen zahlen und unter
diesem neuen eindruck aber das klingt
jetzt das klingt jetzt nicht so etwas
ausgeschlossen dass es zu
steuererhöhungen kommt richtig nein ich
bin gegen steuererhöhungen weil ich der
meinung bin das ist das unkreativ was
man steuern erhöht der staat hat die
aufgabe also politik hat die aufgabe
regierungen haben die aufgabe dann
entsprechend in ihrem haus halten
auch maßnahmen so viel vertrauen zu
gestalten oder die haushalte so zu
gestalten dass auch eingespart mit dem
übrigen haben wir das jetzt wir sind
jetzt auch die wege gehen in die
haushaltsberatung das sieht man da schon
deutlich was mir einsparungen vornimmt
also keine stoff erhöhung mit der
zündung noch einmal weiß ob man nicht
akustisch nicht verstanden hatte aber
auch mal ich bin nicht für
steuererhöhungen
denn wir haben der stadt hat viele
einnahmen und es ist wichtig die
richtigen schwerpunkte setzt vom folgten
gesehen wird die cdu-geführten
bundesregierung die cdu csu geführten
bundesregierung dazu nicht nur in der
lage waren sondern dass aktiv
vorangetrieben haben dass wir jetzt in
dieser guten lage sind und überhaupt so
helfen frau schwesig und ich möchte
einmal noch entschädigung verstehen
besser einmal zu viel schwesig com
versteht ihr kanzlerkandidat ich hätte
fast parteivorsitzender gesagt aber das
ist ja nur fast geworden auf jeden fall
ihr kanzlerkandidat hat bereits gesagt
dass er steuererhöhungen möchte wie
sehen sie das könnte so was wie ein
corona soli am ende helfen
also ich bin erstmal froh dass wir schon
mal kanzlerkandidaten haben der bewiesen
beweist als vizekanzler und
bundesfinanzminister dass diese ganzen
krone ausgaben mehr finanziert werden
die zehn milliarden euro die wir zur
verfügung stellen um die branchen-
gastro hotellerie aber auch
fitnessstudio um denen zu helfen weil
sie jetzt schließen müssen werden aus
den wirtschaftshilfen die schon
eingeplant sind finanziert und olaf
scholz hat keine steuererhöhung in der
korona pandemie und auch keinen corner
sowie vorgeschlagen sondern er hat
deutlich gemacht dass es unabhängig von
der korona zeit immer die debatte gab ob
nicht diejenigen die sehr reich sind zum
beispiel millionäre insgesamt und
besseren steuerlichen beitrag leisten
müssen das ist aber eine debatte die
unabhängig von corona ist herr li na was
glauben sie wie wird am ende das bezahlt
was jetzt ausgegeben wird
dadurch dass der staat mit dem geld das
er einnimmt klug wirtschaften
die schulden die jedes jahr neu aufnimmt
nach und nach reduziert und ansonsten
dafür sorgt dass in der ganzen breite
der wirtschaft wie wir dynamik haben
wachstum haben arbeitsplätze neu
geschaffen werden und bestehende
gesichert werden und das wird eine
interessante auseinandersetzung nächstes
jahr bei der bundestagswahl werden haben
jetzt gerade das konzept von frau
schwesig gehört da ist dann auch schon
der größere mittelständische betrieb der
zahlen musste jetzt gerade über die
krise gekommen ist ich kann für meine
partei nur eins sagen ich gebe eine
politische garantie ab mit der fdp in
der bundesregierung wird es keine
erhöhung der einkommenssteuer oder der
lohnsteuer für die pflegerin in der
altenpflegeeinrichtung geben für den
facharbeiter nicht für die ingenieure
nicht für den mittelstand und die
industrie eine einzige ausnahme mache
ich die apples und dms und die googles
die auch durch die pandemie massiv an
marktanteil gewonnen haben bei denen
sollten wir unverändert das ziel weiter
verfolgen dass die ihren fairen beitrag
zur finanzierung des gemeinwesens zahl
verdoppeln können sie auch diese
garantie geben keine steuererhöhungen
mit der csu steuererhöhungen sind gift
wenn wir aus der krise raus
kommen wollen wir haben jetzt eine
situation dass wir wachstum auch
reduziert und wir müssen dieses wachstum
anreiz und das geht nur wenn man
erleichterungen schafft gerade dann für
die unternehmen für die solo
selbstständigen alle diejenigen die
jetzt unter schwierigsten bedingungen
arbeiten deswegen steuererhöhungen es
vollkommen falsches konzept wenn man
darüber redet wir müssen über neue
entlastungen reden also gegen jene
garant ist ja oder nein
wenn wir mit der fdp regieren dann wird
das mit sicherheit zu keinen
steuererhöhungen kommen aber kein mensch
weiß wäre sanieren sie bitte hier sage
hinkommt zu steuern ein wir sagen es
wird keine steuererhöhungen geben die in
den bereichen stattfinden wo sie
belastungen für die unternehmen für die
einkommen sind und über diejenigen über
die wir reden können über die großen
konzerne die in den letzten jahren wie
es auch christian winter gesagt hat
große umsätze gemacht haben aber wenig
steuern bezahlt haben in deutschland und
europa da müssen wir darüber reden dass
wir die deutlicher mit steuern anfassen
können aber es wird in dem anderen
bereichen zu können steuererhöhungen
kommen
zum abschluss man hat zwar das gefühl es
gibt gar kein anderes thema mehr als
corona aber dennoch schauen wir
natürlich auch alle gebannt auf den
dienstag wo bild im übrigen von 18 uhr
bis 6 uhr live durch senden wird und ich
möchte zum abschluss in der runde einmal
fragen frau klöckner
wie haben sie das heute wahrgenommen
dass donald trump gesagt hat dass die
deutschen ihn eigentlich aus dem amt
haben wollen möchten sie auch dass
donald trump verliert also ich glaube
den amerikanern ist es relativ gleich
was die deutschen wollen die amerikaner
müssen wissen donald trump wie offenbar
nicht dass er so gesagt ja gut hat frank
der präsident war sicherlich vieles er
hat deutsche wurzeln scheint ihm sehr zu
beschäftigen was ist kritik aus
deutschland gibt und die kritik ist
berechtigt und ansonsten haben die
amerikanerinnen und amerikaner zu
wickeln und ich hoffe sie wählen
jemanden wo sie das gefühl haben dass
ganz voran kommt aber das alte
freundschaften nicht beendet werden auch
amerika kann nicht für sich alleine sein
und insofern hätte ist ich werde jetzt
als bundesregierung keine empfehlung
geben aber ich glaube das was wir erlebt
haben unter dem amerikanischen
präsidenten in den vergangenen jahren
bis hat den einen oder anderen staunen
lassen uns etwas oder vermisst ich etwas
freundlicher auszudrücken
also so genannte alternative fakten das
anheizen und das polarisieren in einem
land und vor allen dingen das kappen auf
von von den handelsbeziehungen und von
freundschaften
das ist keine kleinen kein gutes rezept
für eine friedliche und gute kooperative
zukunft also ich übersetze dass man sie
drücken schon ein bisschen joe biden die
daumen ich drücke den amerikanern die
damen wechsel sich klug entscheiden
frau schwesig für wen sind sie bei
dieser us-wahl ich nehme an nicht für
donald trump bei den
auseinandersetzungen die sie mit der
us-regierung um nord stream zum beispiel
hatten
es ist schon abenteuerlich das wirklich
bei uns der hafen mukran bedroht wird
das hat uns sehr erschüttert denn so
geht man nicht mit freunden um und man
kann ja zu nord stream unterschiedlicher
meinung sein aber deutschland muss immer
noch eigenständig entscheiden können wie
sie die energieversorgung sicherstellen
und das da die amerikanische regierung
versucht ihre wirtschaftlichen
interessen so brutal durchzusetzen das
sollte ein ende haben als
ministerpräsidentin steht mit keine
wahlempfehlung zu aber als
sozialdemokraten möchte ich nicht
verheimlichen dass ich mir wünschen
würde dass die demokraten und joe biden
diese wahl gewinnen und vor allem
wünsche ich mir dass nach dieser wahl
das deutsch amerikanische verhältnis
sich wieder verbessert denn wir feiern
30 jahre deutsche einheit in diesem jahr
vor allem auf 30 jahre mecklenburg
vorpommern und ich möchte nicht mehr
dass wir bedroht werden sondern dass wir
freundschaftlich miteinander umgehen
auch in schwierigen fragen denn wir
haben den amerikanern auch viel zu
verdanken
glauben sie es mir da muss ich doch noch
einmal nachhaken sie sagen sie sprechen
das nord stream die nordstream
problematik an heißt dass die arbeiten
lieber mit jemandem zusammen der
menschen im tiergarten ermorden lässt
der ein oppositionspolitiker vergiften
lässt ist dass dann die bessere wahl
mit wladimir putin zusammen zu arbeiten
es geht ja nicht darum mit welchem
präsidenten dir zusammenarbeiten sondern
sie haben mich ja konkret gefragt wie es
steht um die spannung weil
die amerikanischen
weil zb amerikanische senatoren den
hafenkran bedrohen die geschäftsführung
und des nord stream zwei projekt ist ein
projekt nach meiner tiefen überzeugung
was für deutschland und ganz europa
wichtig ist denn wir brauchen stabile
energieversorgung wir haben jetzt hier
gerade viel über wirtschaftliche folgen
gesprochen
wir müssen sicherstellen dass die
energieversorgung der zukunft auch
gesichert ist und noch mal man kann
unterschiedlicher meinung sein für
diesem projekt aber drohung gegenüber
geschäftsführung gegenüber unternehmen
in unserem land ich glaube das ist nicht
der richtige weg
jetzt haben sie zwar meine frage nicht
nach wladimir putin beantwortet aber ich
gebe dann nochmal weiter zu alexander
dobrindt herr dobrindt für joe biden
oder für donald trump ich bin für eine
enge partnerschaft mit amerika nicht nur
aus gründen der wirtschaftlichen
zusammenarbeit auch aus dieser engen
traditionen der wir in den vergangenen
jahrzehnten die die politik auch in der
welt gut miteinander abgestimmt haben
und dass das zurzeit nicht möglich ist
ich glaube das ist keine kluge und keine
gute entwicklung und die sollte sich
nach der wahl ändern unabhängig von wem
und welchem präsidenten amerika regiert
wird also mit beiden wäre es
wahrscheinlich einfacher oder das kann
man nicht sagen ob es unbedingt für
europa einfacher wird mit beiden die
amerikaner haben eine klare agenda
eigentlich auf der welt die sich
unterscheidet von dem was wir den
vergangenen jahrzehnten gesehen haben
und deswegen ich hoffe dass vieles davon
auch rhetorik aus dem wahlkampf waren
sich das nach der wahl doch deutliche
erlittener teilen sie die analyse von
donald trump dass sich die deutschen
wünschen dass endlich abgewählt wird ja
ganz mehrheitlich wünschen sich die
deutschen gewiss dass es in den
vereinigten staaten wieder einen
präsidenten gibt und das hat gar nichts
mit der partei zu tun der sein eigenes
land wieder versöhnt menschen nicht
gegeneinander ausspielt der sich an
internationales recht auch halten will
die vereinigten staaten das war mal das
weltweite leuchtfeuer für
marktwirtschaft rechtsstaat und
demokratie und heute haben sie einen
präsidenten der unternehmen kommandos
erteilt wie sie zu produzieren haben
der demokratische institutionen
verunglückt minderheiten ausgrenzt
und der die rechtsstaatlichkeit
mindestens in ihrer akzeptanz gefährdet
durch die art und weise wie er höchste
richter positionen besetzt und deshalb
wünsche ich den vereinigten staaten
einfach wieder dass hier die vereinigten
staaten sein können als eben das
weltweite leuchtfeuer der liberalität
und das hat nicht was zu tun mit einer
freiheits statue sondern mit der frage
wie man den eigenen werten entspricht
und ihnen gerecht wird
herzlichen dank für die analyse was
donald trump angeht an die beteiligten
herzlichen dank aber auch zu der
emotionalen diskussion zu corona
festhalten können wir das alexander
dobrindt und christian lindner beides
zusammen mit bild ein pflegeheim
besuchen werden mehrere mehrere gerne
auch da ist und aktiv gerne auch das
herzlichen dank fürs zuschauen das war's
für heute abend mit die richtigen fragen
es geht bereits weiter mit einer großen
sendung am dienstag zu den us-wahlen ich
habe es bereits angekündigt insgesamt
zwölf stunden ist bild dann live das
war's mit dem corona talk von heute
abend machen sie es gut auf wiedersehen
[Musik]